part of life is competition you know
it's you know the only time competition
ends is
death but you know political life
economic life uh
cultural life is engaged continuously in
creativity and competition and uh the
the problem I have with that as as I
mentioned earlier just before we began
the podcast is that uh
at a certain point you want to put
barriers to Monopoly and if you're in a
really able competitor you're going to
create a monopoly that's what Peter till
says is a natural course of things it's
what I learned and uh basically in the
Boston Consulting Group if you're a very
able competitor you'll create scale
advantages that give you the ability to
lock out your competition and as a prime
minister I want to assure that there is
competition in the market so you have to
limit uh limit this competitive power at
a certain point and that becomes
increasingly hard uh in the in the world
where everything is intermissed where do
you define market segments where do you
define uh Monopoly uh how do you do that
that is very that that actually
conceptually I find very challenging
because of all the dozens of political
of economic reforms that I've made
the most difficult part is the
conceptual part once you have you've
ironed it out you say here's what I want
to do here's the right thing to do then
you have a practical problem of
overcoming Union resistance political
resistance press calumny uh uh you know
opponents but from this or that corner
that's a practical matter but if you
have it conceptually defined you can
move ahead to uh reformed economies or
reform education or reform
Transportation fine in the question of
The Growing Power of large companies
big tech companies to monopolize the
markets because they're better at it
they provide a service they provide it
at lower cost it rapidly declined costs
where do you stop where do you uh where
do you stop in a monopoly power is a
crucial question because it also becomes
now a political question if you are mass
enormous amount of economic power which
is information power you know that also
monopolizes the political process which
creates these are real questions that
are not obvious I don't have an obvious
answer because as I said as a 19th
century Democrat these are questions of
the 21st century which people should
should begin to think do you have a
solution to that
the solution of monopoly's growing
arbitrarily unstoppably in power an
economic power and therefore in
political power I mean some of that is
regulation some of that is competition
you know where
to put to draw the line
it's not breaking up a T and T you know
it's not that simple
well I believe in the power of
competition that there will always be
somebody that challenges the big guys
especially in the space of AI the more
open source movements are taking hold
the more the little guy can become the
big guy so you're saying basically the
regulatory the the regulatory uh
instrument is the market
in large part in most part that's the
hope maybe I'm a dreamer that's been in
many ways by policy up to now
okay that the best regulator
uh is the market the best regulator in
economic uh in economic activity is the
market
and the best regulator in political
matters is a political Market that's
called elections that's what that's what
regulates you know you have a lousy
government uh and people make lousy
decisions well you don't need uh you
know the wise men raised above the uh
you know the the masses to decide what
is good and what is bad let the masses
decide let them vote every four years or
whatever and they throw you up by the
way it happened to me there's life after
political death there's actually
political life I was re-elected five or
six times and this is my sixth term so
you know that I believe in that I'm not
sure
I'm not sure that in economic matters in
the geometric growth of uh tech
companies that you'll always have the
little guy the Nimble mammal that will
come out and slay the dinosaurs or
overcome the dinosaurs uh which is
essentially what you said yeah I
wouldn't count out the little guy you
wouldn't count out the loom well I hope
you're right